[Música]
la ley de inmigración promulgada en
Florida por el gobernador ron de santis
entraba en vigor este primero de julio y
mientras el estado se prepara los
migrantes ven las consecuencias de
santis quien además recientemente lanzó
su precandidatura presidencial espera
expulsar a los ciudadanos indocumentados
y culpa al presidente Joe biden de la
crisis en el país vamos al análisis con
Tomás Kennedy Vocero de la coalición de
inmigrantes de Florida y quien se
conecta con nosotros desde Miami
bienvenido aquí a France 24 la ley da 12
millones de dólares para enviar a los
migrantes indocumentados a Estados
demócratas Por qué no hay una acción
Federal en ese sentido
bueno básicamente en este país los
gobiernos estatales tienen mucha
discreción
en la forma que pueden legislar y en la
forma en que pueden alocar fondos
nosotros en realidad creemos que la la
el dinero está haciendo usado de una
forma no apropiada y que esto es un un
gasto de recursos que podrían ir a cosas
más productivas no pero bueno
Lamentablemente el Gobierno Federal no
tiene mucha autoridad para pagar este
tipo de de
Y si esto llegase a pasar que los
migrantes se vayan ya sea porque sean
deportados a Estados demócratas o porque
ellos mismos prefieran irse de Florida
se podría quedar el estado entonces sin
una mano de obra y cuál puede ser la
consecuencia que enfrenten las empresas
que no utilicen el mecanismo de y verify
Bueno sí el el gobernador y la
legislatura acaban de pasar una de las
leyes más antimigrantes en la historia
moderna de este país hace convierte un
delito agravado cruzar la línea
fronteriza hacia la Florida con una
persona indocumentada aunque sea su
familiar o su esposa su esposa y también
como lo dijiste obliga a empresas
privadas que tienen más de 25 empleados
usar este sistema diversi Desde que la
ley fue firmada por el gobernador y ni
siquiera ha entrado en efecto estamos
viendo lugares de trabajo proyectos de
construcción el sector agrícola con una
falta de mano de obra grave estamos
viendo grandes compañías constructoras
que están
contratando a firmas de abogados de
migración para hacer sesiones
informativas no con los empleados pero
con los empleadores para saber cómo esto
les va a afectar algo que en realidad
nunca había visto en este estado y es
por el miedo que ha causado esto muchas
personas emigrantes muchas familias
están diciendo me voy a ir a otro estado
me hubiera trabajar a otro lugar porque
no quieren correr el riesgo de ser
deportados de ser echados de terminar en
un centro de detención y uno se tiene
que acordar que o sea la la temporada de
agricultura en este estado va por etapas
y acá se acaba de terminar la mayoría de
las cosechas no entonces muchos de los
trabajadores que se están yendo ahora
están diciendo que no van a volver a la
Florida para cosechar las naranjas las
frutillas o sea todas las cosas que
nosotros después disfrutamos en nuestros
hogares no O sea que estamos viendo
algo grave
estos va a empeorar una vez que la ley
entra en efecto en julio primero y
realmente es daño propio que se hizo la
legislatura del gobernador porque el
gobernador está corriendo para
presidente y tiene que
competir con el con Donald Trump como el
candidato más antimigrante y más de
derecha desafortunadamente usted
menciona dos sectores que se están
viendo bastante afectados con los
migrantes yéndose del Estado menciona la
construcción y la agricultura a pesar de
que todavía no estamos en temporada de
cosecha pero también hay otros como los
restaurantes y la hotelería la ley Busca
alguna manera de llenar estos vacíos
propone algo al respecto
bueno la ley Deja que compañías privadas
que tienen menos de 25 empleados no usen
este sistema pero menos de 25 empleados
es muy poquito para ciertas proyectos
por ejemplo para una construcción
de de tamaño mediano grande se necesita
mucho más gente que que esa para llevar
adelante
un proyecto agrícola o la industria
hospitalaria en este estado se necesita
mucha más que eso Entonces realmente
empleadores gente con pequeños negocios
contratistas se están viendo en una
situación grave y se están sintiendo
realmente apretados yo estuve en mocali
que es una parte rural del estado de la
semana pasada
reuniéndome no solo con trabajadores
pero como te dije con con empleadores
con gente que tiene pequeños negocios
estaban tratando de ver formas de cómo
van a poder seguir trabajando y la gente
Realmente está sintiendo mucha presión y
está muy preocupada con lo que va a
pasar con esta ley y si contratan a una
persona indocumentada van a tener multas
de más de mil dólares por día o sea es
sí Tomás y usted cree que puede haber un
efecto dominó y otros estados
republicanos apliquen leyes similares
Chau con efecto dominó cuando se propuso
esta ley en la Florida Era realmente una
locura porque lo que tenía originalmente
decía que si usted tenía una persona
indocumentada en su hogar o en su auto
adentro del Estado aunque sea su
familiar su hermano su hermana su primo
su prima su esposa su esposo su hijo su
hija era un delito agravado de tercer
grado que te pueden dar cinco años en la
cárcel eso era la el texto original y
Nosotros con mucho trabajo lo pudimos
cambiar a último momento con una semana
de que se a que se termine la sesión
legislativa esta misma ley en su versión
original con lo que acabo de escribir
acaba de ser aprobada en el estado de
Kansas y están loca que el Gobernador
republicano de Kansas la vetó y la
legislatura la la la la la pasó igual o
sea que estamos viendo la duplicación
ahora mismo el otro estados Tomás
Kennedy Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
las 24
No gracias a ustedes por la invitación y
nosotros seguimos con las noticias
internacionales del momento
[Música]